This is Matt Gray. He gives high-fives.
And this is a cardboard cut-out of Matt Gray,
assembled by a crack team of professionals.
But which one can get more high-fives in ten minutes?
Tonight, on the mean streets of York, We find out.
This is the Matt Gray High Five Face Off.
Well you join us here on this cloudy December afternoon in York.
Cut-out's in position, and Matt's ready, so lets start the clock.
Both of them have ten minutes to get as many high fives as possible
Slow start for the cut-out there, but Matt is straight off with
a Left-Handed Double-Take Spin, an excellent opening gambit for 2 points.
A bit of interest from some local kids there, but..
No, only one high five given there, that's just 1 point for the cut-out.
Matt's going for the pensioners, she spurned him but...
Yes! That's good.
The band have struck up by the cut-out and it looks quiet...
No, wait! Thank you, madam. Glad you enjoyed it.
Three minutes in, and it looks like Matt's having a bit of trouble.
Following people doesn't help that much-
Oh and that's a Raised-Child Slow Slap; 1 point for the cut-out there.
Matt: High-five?
Matt: High-five, sir?
He's asking the questions, but he's not getting the answer he wants.
That's not a high-five, That's a punch in the hand!
Discussions of some kind-
Oh! That's a high-ten!
That's the kind of professionalism we've come to expect from a contender of this caliber. Sheer class.
The cut-out, left mostly ignored, with a low in the crowd,
I'm fairly certain Matt's pulling ahead.
One from the child, and one from the mother!
Housewives favorite Matt Gray strikes again.
Big, big crowds here today-
Oh, whats this?
Oh that's incredible! A Double-Granny Simultaneous Side Swipe!
I haven't seen one of those since Italy in the semi-finals in 1983-
And where did she come from? Out of nowhere, that's where!
Out of nowhere and back to the streets and-
He's got a second one! Unbelievable!
Even if the kids in hats go for the cut-out, surely it doesn't stand a chance now!
Matt Gray in full on bounce mode now, surely nothing can stop this contender.
He's absolutely in the zone and the cut-out is just left standing still
One!
Two!
Three!
Four in a row! This is incredible!
She's not gonna be enough to save the cut-out's chances and with
the clock starting to run short-
Oh! That's a full on Power-Blast! That's got to hurt!
But it just doesn't show!
And even the crowds at the cut-out seem to sense the impending crushing defeat! And-
OH MY WORD! It seems you CAN get the staff these days!
No contest here; Matt Gray is dozens of high-fives ahead of his competitor.
The cut-out just getting scorned looks from teenage girls-
Oh but Matt Gray is ahead with the under-18 crowd and the over-30s. As I said before,
Housewives favourite, Ink and card can't compete there!
One! Two! Three!
Even the police, it seems, have no interest in a free high-five from the cut-out-
Oh but what's this!? It's a traffic warden!
Can he get the traffic warden to...?-
YES! YES! UNBELIEVABLE!
The first authority figure of the night, the points go to Matt Gray in the final ten seconds!
The cut-out, I'm sure, thinks it's all over.
OH IT IS NOW! A Flying Two-Handed Busted Jump with Follow-through!
[BUZZER] Never attempted in professional competition before, but it worked!
The final scores, ladies and gentlemen! The end of the round, the end of the contest
It's a staggering 112 to Matt Gray
And only 23 to his cardboard replica.
That has been the Matt Gray High Five Face Off.
The victor, Matt Gray!